In the last video, I hinted
that this was leading to a
discussion of an elastic money
supply-- or a supply of money
that can change depending on
the needs for the money.
So before we go there-- and I
took a little hiatus and told
you a little bit about
treasuries because that's a
critical component-- let's
review what the
money supply even is.
So there were two definitions.
When we had originally talked
about kind of an M0, I talked
about just the gold reserves,
but now we're going to expand
that definition a little bit
and I think you can tell--
I've got a lot of questions
about this-- eventually
getting off the gold reserve
system and we will get there
and we're kind of already there,
but now I'll consider
the base money supply
as Federal Reserve
deposits and notes.
So in this reality that I just
created, all of the Federal
Reserve deposits have
essentially been turned into
notes, but if this bank didn't
want all cash, it could have
had some of this as just a
checking account with the
Federal Reserve bank.
So a Federal Reserve note and
a Federal Reserve deposit
account is essentially
the same thing.
A note is just a little
bit more fungible.
You can hand it to someone and
then they can hand it to
someone else, while a checking
account or demand account with
the Federal Reserve bank, you
have to kind of do a wire
transfer or write a check, et
cetera, but that is the base
money supply.
You could call that
base money.
And that's essentially the size
of the liabilities of the
Federal Reserve, in very broad
terms. We'll go into detail on
the actual Federal
Reserve's balance
sheet in the near future.
So in this example right now,
our base money supply is 200--
let's call it dollars now.
Let's move away from
gold pieces.
Let's just say a dollar equals
a gold piece for the sake of
our instruction right now.
So our base money supply--
and I'll call that M0.
And that's the cash out there,
which are the Federal Reserve
notes plus the Federal Reserve
demand deposits.
So for example, this could have
been just 100, like a
checking account at the reserve
bank and then this
over here would have been a
checking account instead.
But it would still be considered
part of the base
money supply because if this
bank, who had a checking
account, says, I just want that
in terms of notes, then
the Federal Reserve bank will
just issue notes and cancel
out this checking account and it
would turn back into notes.
So they're equivalent.
They're just a different way
of keeping track of it.
So that's the base
money supply.
Now, a slightly broader
definition
of the money supply.
We could call this bank money.
It's sometimes referred to as
that and the formal definition
is M1-- and that's essentially
that notion that I went over I
think almost 10 videos ago--
how much money do
people think they have?
And that's the amount of money
in demand deposit accounts.
So that in this case,
that's this.
So all the people in this bank,
they think they have
$100 there, right?
That's $100 that they think that
they have that they can
write checks against.
And then this bank
also has another $100.
And so the base money supply--
no, that's not right.
No, no, sorry.
They don't have $100.
Why am I saying $100?
Let's see.
This bank had $100 in gold and
it could lend out up to $200
in-- or it could put
out up to $200 in
checking deposit accounts.
So it has $200.
Right, that's what I was--
because we talked about
earlier in the last video that
we have a 50% reserve ratio,
which tells us that if this
bank has $100 in reserves,
that it can essentially manage--
or it can issue $200
in demand deposit accounts.
And we went over that many times
on how that happens.
And then this bank
can do the same.
It'll have $200 in demand
deposit accounts.
And so the total amount of money
that people think they
have, either in demand deposit
accounts-- in this situation,
I'm assuming that all of the
cash is sitting in the reserve
bank, although we do know that
some of this is going to be
sitting around circulating.
But let's just say we live in
a world where everyone uses
debit cards all the time
and no-one uses cash.
And I think we're heading to
that world very quickly.
And as we'll see soon, that
actually increases the money
supply when you do that.
But anyway, I don't want to
go too technical just yet.
But the M1, which is the total
amount of demand deposit
accounts in our universe,
is $400.
And this relationship makes
a lot of sense because our
reserve requirements are 50%.
So we can kind of assume that
banks tend to get as close to
their reserve requirement as
they can because they don't
get interest on reserves.
They make interest on the loans
that they make against
demand accounts.
So if the reserve requirement
were 10% and our base money
was $200, we would probably see
$2,000 in the M1 supply.
So my question to you is-- and
maybe you want to pause and
think about this is-- how can
the government or the central
bank or, how can the economy,
increase or
decrease the money supply?
And I guess the first question
is, why would you want to
increase or decrease
the money supply?
Well, let's say we're in this
world already and we only have
these two banks.
And we have an M1
supply of $400.
But let's say the
economy expands.
We have more goods
and services that
we're able to produce.
Maybe we have immigrants come
in so we have more labor.
Maybe we have some innovative
technology.
Or maybe it's just seasonal.
Maybe it's the crop planting
season so a lot of farmers
need their cash in order
to hire people
to plant the crops.
So that's another time where
you'd want more money.
If you don't increase the money
supply at those times
when you have economic expansion
or there's just more
demand because of some type of
seasonal fluctuaction-- if you
don't increase the money, then
what you're going to do is
money's going to become
more expensive.
And I'll do a whole video
on that so don't get too
confused, but money getting
more expensive means that
interest rates will go up.
And if money becomes too
expensive, then some good
projects, maybe some farmers who
might have planted seeds,
wouldn't be able to-- and so
you would kind of restrict
economic expansion.
But we'll have a whole other
discussion on when does it
make sense to expand
or contract money.
Let's just talk now about how
you would actually do it.
So there's two ways.
I just said if this reserve
requirement were 10%, then
these banks could create more
checking accounts, right?
They could lend out more money
and create more checking
accounts if the reserve
requirement were 10%.
If it was 10%, then you would
have an M1 of $2,000, right?
It would be 10 times this
instead of two times this.
And that is considered one of
the tools of the Federal
Reserve bank.
Because we've said in the past
that the Federal Reserve bank
actually sets these reserve
requirements.
But the problem with that tool,
if you think about it,
is, if we made a reserve
requirement 10%, right?
And all of a sudden all of these
banks started lending a
lot more money and they
only had 10%.
The ratio of reserves to
checking accounts were 10%.
Think about what would happen
if we wanted to raise the
reserve requirement
back to 50%.
Then all of the banks-- they'd
only have 10% reserves.
How would they get
back to 50%?
All of these banks would have to
either start selling assets
or unwinding loans.
It would be a very
messy situation.
If you were to lower the reserve
requirement and then
wanted to actually increase it
again, you would actually make
a lot of banks become
undercapitalized, because most
banks just operate right
at where they need to.
So you really don't want to mess
around with this reserve
requirement much.
So the question is, if you're
not going to change the
reserve requirement, which is
the ratio of the reserves to
checking accounts, if you're not
going to mess with that,
the only other way that you
can actually increase the
number of checking accounts is
if somehow you can increase
the reserves.
If you can somehow add some
actual reserves over here.
So my question is, how
can you do that?
Well, let's just say that--
we're hopefully already
reasonably familiar with
fractional reserve banking.
So you might have seen it
coming, that that also applies
to the central bank.
So the central bank right now,
all of its deposits were
directly backed by gold, 1:1.
But there's nothing to stop
this bank from also doing
fractional reserve lending.
And actually, the central bank
has no reserve requirement.
And that's because to some
degree, it can always provide
the liquidity because its notes
are obligations of the
government.
So it can always tax more people
to back up its loans.
So what essentially the Federal
Reserve can do is--
and this is the printing press
of the base money supply that
people talk about.
But there's two printing
presses.
There's the base money printing
press and then
there's the leverage
printing press.
So if this increases-- well,
I'll do a whole video on that
another-- I don't want to get
too technical because I
realize I'm running
out of time.
So what the Federal Reserve
could do in this situation is
it can print some notes.
So let's say it prints 100 of
the notes, right, and those
are just-- it literally just
prints those dollars.
It pays the treasury to print
it for them, but it creates
these notes and then of course,
offsetting that is a
liability, right?
Notes outstanding,
100 liability.
And then what it does is, it
takes these $100-- I mean,
these are literally dollar bills
although it could be
some type of demand account or
whatever, but take these $100
bills that it printed and
then it can buy treasury
securities.
So what happens if it takes
these $100 bills and buys
treasuries?
And the treasuries don't
have to be issued by
the government anymore.
Because whenever the government
does issue
treasuries, it's bought
by just a bunch of
people in the world.
There's always a bunch of
treasuries sitting out there
as long as the treasury
has some debt.
So I was holding the treasuries
and let's say that
this is the central bank.
I was holding some some of these
government IOUs, right,
that I had bought from
the government.
And the Federal Reserve,
they have this $100.
Let me draw that in green.
So they just buy the
treasury from me.
Maybe I don't want to sell it
at the current price so they
have to pay me a little bit more
than the current price in
order for me to part with it--
and I'll do a whole other
video on what that means and
how that changes the yield
curve and all of that, but I
just want to get you to that
base notion that the treasury
essentially creates a notes
outstanding liability and has
an offsetting $100 of dollar
bills that it just created or
prints-- and then it can use
those $100 bills to buy
treasuries, or government
IOUs, in the open market.
And now what happens here?
Well, these $100 bills, these
are now treasuries.
And my question to you
is, what am I-- I
was holding a treasury.
It was sitting in my mattress.
What am I now going-- now
I don't have a treasury.
I have $100.
What am I going to do
with that $100?
Well, I'm going to deposit
it in the bank.
I'm going to deposit
So this is me depositing
my $100.
Maybe I deposited it up here,
but-- and my checking account
grows a little bit, but
what's the net effect?
Now all of a sudden the banking
system, the national
banking system, has more
currency, more dollar
reserves, that apply to
its reserve ratio.
So now it got my $100 deposit.
Now it can also do another
$100 of lending.
So I would have essentially
increased the base-- so now
the M0 goes from $200 to $300
right, because I have $300 in
notes outstanding.
And now my M1-- I took that $100
bill that the treasury
gave me, deposited it
in a bank account.
Now I have a bank account that
says $100 and then because of
a 50% reserve requirement, the
bank can issue another loan.
I know it's getting messy.
$400-- so essentially
our M1 is now $600.
So just like that, just by
printing money and issuing
treasuries, the central
bank was able to
increase the M1 by $200.
I'll do more videos on this.
I don't want to confuse
you too much.
See you soon.